hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar part one
achieving laboratory operational
excellence
through abbis clinical chemistry
solutions
i am michelle ashton of labrutz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
and brought to you by abbott we
encourage you to participate today
by submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit any technical issues here as
well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits window at the bottom of your
screen to obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
marvin berman
manager scientific services diagnostics
division
of abbott laboratories dr berman is
responsible for scientific support
and collaboration in clinical and
immunoassay
immunoassay diagnostics he has
extensive experience in developing and
supporting both immunoassay and clinical
chemistry diagnostic
assays having held positions in research
and development
manufacturing technical operations
validations and business excellence
christina fabro marketing manager for
latin america
and canada will begin the presentation
welcome to abbott core diagnostics
session on achieving
operational excellence in clinical
chemistry
i'll start with a disclaimer this
webinar is intended as a scientific
educational session to inform both
laboratory and healthcare professionals
of the latest researched and published
data
the menu is not available in all markets
if you have any questions or require any
information
please contact your local abbott
representative or add a comment in the
chat
the following session will highlight
abbott's commitment
to helping your laboratory achieve
excellence in clinical chemistry
sigma strong as this image shows
and represents a combination of two
things
abbot's six sigma assay performance you
see the performance curve
and harmonized systems these are
platforms
such as alinity and architect both these
two components
allow you to obtain highly accurate test
results
you will hear about sigma strong from
our speaker dr marvin berman
who's going to illustrate the key
benefits
to sigma strong and abbot's new approach
to clinical chemistry
we will focus in on three areas on how
we're bringing assay formulation
improvements
and continuing to leverage innovative
technologies
to deliver operational excellence in
these three focus areas
the first one is confidence in six six
sigma
clinical chemistry results having high
performance assets and the confidence
that that provides
and the and the contribution to
operational excellence
the second area will be assay
productivity through
both assay design and system design
these components can help laboratories
achieve
operational excellence and the third
area will be
total value of ownership improvements
so the objectives of today's session
will be
to look at the role of sigma metrics in
laboratory medicine
an overview of clsi guidelines and
measuring intervals
and how does innovation in assay design
analytical technologies and
instrumentation
help deliver high quality results taking
the lab
to a next level in operational
excellence
i will now turn it over to dr marvin
berman from scientific affairs
to continue the presentation
thank you christina
so labs need to provide reliable high
quality results to support
clinician decision making avid works to
develop assays aligned to the latest
clsi guidelines
which delivers six sigma analytical
quality
to help address these challenges
so what is clsi clsi is the clinical
and lab standards standardization
institute
and they are a group that develops
guidelines
for laboratories and manufacturers based
on input from
manufacturers laboratorians
regulatory bodies key opinion leaders
experts in the field
and they develop these guidelines that
will meet the needs of all these groups
for example ep 17 on measuring interval
was just released
they the group this guideline was
developed because
measuring interval had many names
calibration range
linearity range upper limit and so it
wants to modernize these terms
as well as provide guidance in how a
measuring interval should be defined
and so measuring interval is defined by
the sensitivity
such as women to blank limited detection
limit of quantitation
linearity method comparison and
precision
so avid as part of these uh csi teams
uh uses these metrics as well so
limit of blank is the value you get
when you have no analyte present in the
sample
limit of detection is the value you get
at the lowest cost
concentration of analyte that you can
read and llq or limit of quantitation
is the lowest concentration of analyte
that can be detected
based on both the bias and precision
so measuring a tool the analytical
measuring interval is defined as the
range of what specimen concentrations
are measured within the medical and lab
needs
for accuracy with no dilution
concentration or other pre-treatment
not part of the standard or routine
measurement process
inclusive of dilutions or pre-treatments
that need no user intervention
the extended measuring interval shown in
purple is the range in which
concentrations are measured with
appropriate accuracy
by diluting the specimen taken before
taking a measurement with the developed
measurement process
and so the whole range shown below is
called the reportable interview interval
and it's the range that includes
the analytical measuring interval or ami
the extended measurement
interval or emi and extends as far down
as the limit of load detection
using these harmonized techniques
laboratories are able to compare
performance of assays across different
manufacturers
so six sigma quality is a good
measurement of
performance of assays across different
manufacturers and systems
it's derived by the equation in the
lower right it's your total allowable
error minus your bias divided by your
precision cv
so in the graph on the left you can see
in the center is your target
and any any
difference from the target is called the
bias and
the precision around the target is your
cv
and in the lower right hand corner that
area represents the
defects so sigma values
grades from one to six one a low sigma
value
would would represent 690 000 defects
per million
versus six sigma represents 3.4 defects
per million
so as you increase in sigma value your
defects go down
and laboratories want to be at least in
the fourth to sixth range
for the assays that they're running
so again six sigma what does that mean
it's again confidence in your six sigma
clinical chemistry results
it's having essays thoughtfully designed
and system designed to meet users needs
and it's a total value
of ownership a partnership between
abbott and the
users or lab oratorians and i'm going to
talk a little bit
about the first one confidence
so how can you be sure that you can be
uh have communism the values that you're
reporting and that the assays that
you're using
will meet the operational excellence
that you desire
so when avid is designing new assays or
system designs
they look at metrics to
assess themselves when we when we build
these assays
they should have quality have customer
key expert engagement
commutability should have critical menu
items and efficiency
so for quality does it meet modern
expectations such as the clsi
guidelines are we consistent in our
labeling across all our product lines
do we meet consistent sigma levels and
when we do
accuracy studies are we using a
recognized standard
that laboratories can use to verify
our performance customer key expert
engagement is important
in getting customer inputs on features
that they want
and need having early adopters
studies where customers can give
feedback on the performance of the
product early in development
and scientific collaboration with key
opinion leaders
to know what features the essays should
have
such as should it be a serum assay only
or should be a serum urine
immutability is important we strive to
make sure that
when we go from a new platform such as
architectural lindy
that results are commutable and as they
perform equivalently or better
we want to make sure our assays are
standardized
correctly to international standards
that customers get expected values
and we also work on developing
pediatric pediatric reference ranges
menu is important are we providing the
assays that
are needed like hba1c drugs of abuse
therapeutic drug monitoring and
efficiency
do our systems have air proof designs
can you load the reagents
while the instrument is still running
can you have on-board materials so you
don't have to stop the instrument
to calibrate every time can the
instrument
fit nicely into a small lab or a big
reference lab is it easy to have lab
personnel run the instrument
can i load higher load capacity samples
on
the instrument all important features to
look at when you're designing an assay
or a system
so again it's a collaboration we use
guidelines prepared by organizations
such as clsi
and manufacturing and we work to
meet the needs of critical labs uh by
listening to both the clinical labs and
the guy
and following the guidelines to give a
product that meets
customer expectations
the sigma metrics are important to us uh
here's an example from album in bcg
you can see that has a precision percent
cv of 1.4 percent
it has a bias of 4.8 percent
which leads to signal value of 6.6
which is where you want to be
and then on the next slide we have a
list of
six of our new olivi clinical chem
assays
and you can see all of them have uh
sigma values greater than six
they all use a recognized set standard
from nist or irm
and we did the testing
accuracy testing at a medical decision
point and where we still get
very good cvs about one percent
so now assay productivity through essay
and system design
so the new avid assays
are built with with the customer in mind
we have optimized the kit and cartridge
size
to make it easier for customers to load
uh clinical chemistry assays
we have increased uh onboard stability
increased calibration stability
all to allow for a higher throughput and
less customer intervention
challenges there are many manual
processes that hamper efficiency
and cause increased risk of error or
inconsistency
avid develops assays and systems
utilizing innovative technologies that
enable streamlined workflows
reduce hidden costs and improve
efficiency to help address some of these
challenges
avid uses unique and proven technologies
we use we offer pre-analytical
processes like sample interference
indices
to evaluate uh
hemolytic samples lipid samples like
taric samples
to make so that you know you can make
sure that there's no potential
interference
and we have cloud of bubble detection to
make sure the sample is aspirated
correctly
as well we have technologies such as the
ict module
smart washing and flex rate that i'll go
into
in more detail in the next slide
so abbott offers an ict module that
can measure the electrolyte sodium
potassium and chloride
you can get uh what a single analyte or
you can get all three analyte responses
in a single sample it offers sixty
thousand determinations per module
cds less than or equal to one percent
and
automated maintenance
here's a little here's some of the data
from the uh
ict module uh you can see that
the performance of different uh tube
types
lithium heifer and sodium heparin
lithium heparin are serum
separator tubes and serum separated
tubes
cvs are are very comparable across the
different tube types
as well interference by ectaric
hemolytic and lepimic samples is very
low this means that
you're going to have less issues for
having to do reruns or repeating draws
and gives a market system turnaround
time and of course less maintenance
uh avid offers a smartwatch technology
that ensures minimal
sample to sample carryover avid has
established that
the carrier specifications meet or
exceed the bias
or total out allowable error
requirements for each assay
these specs are derived from recognized
international criteria
from sclea nacb ricoh's
avid kumkum systems also have an optimum
sampling sequence feature
which automatically determines the
sampling sequence
to minimize uh what smartwatch
uh when it's not when so that you can do
a good flow
of sampling without having to do a smart
wash every time
so the smartwatch technology was tested
across three instruments
uh it looked at low sample volumes of 15
microliters
and high sample volumes of 35
microliters and use the sample
surface antigen that is known to
can get that it's known that it could
cause carryover if you don't have the
correct wash
system set up and you can see carryover
was less than 0.01 parts per million and
passed all our criteria
so this is important because it provides
confidence in results
that you can ensure that you're
providing the proper patient care
it means you don't need to use pipette
tips and now quality to avoid carryover
contamination and samples
no need to run all amino acids first to
avoid carryover
in chemistry systems and no need for
carrier
carryover evasion protocols that could
lead to inconsistent turnaround times
luxury technology what is that it
extends the linearity of chemistry
enzyme assays
by using two absorbent three-time
windows
in green you have a main read window and
in orange you have the flex rate read
time
you can see a normal sample with the
green dots
it's linear across the main read time
and would have been measured and would
be measured in the main read window
the orange sample with the orange dots
you can see it's flat
in the main read window and so you
wouldn't get an accurate meeting
reading of the sample and another
systems would be rejected for out of
range
but on the avid system you can flex to
the flex read time and you can see in
that read window
the points are linear and you can get a
reading
so what does this mean to a customer it
means you don't have to
repeat that sample try to figure out
what
alternate division to use take time to
put a new sample on
like this you have confidence that that
sample will be red
or the machine will use the flex free
time to read it saving you time and cost
here's the performance of our enzyme
assays
it shows slopes around one correlation
is around one
you can see the wide range of the each
of the assays shown
and on the left you have correlation
graphs
showing the linear versus architect
commutability of samples across both
platforms
dr marvin berman has reviewed abbott's
commitment to operational excellence
the lab plays a critical role in the
health care system
providing results to patients they serve
sigma strong
provides you with these three benefits
that marvin has reviewed
let's go through it again the first is
confidence in stigma clinical chemistry
results
having a high performing six sigma assay
can allow you to potentially decrease
the amount of workarounds
change qc practices
and also be confident in the results
that you're reporting
and help you with that operational
excellence
we went through the assay productivity
looking at assay design
and system design just highlighted right
now
so in particular for the system design
component
technologies such as ict integrated chip
technology for your sodium potassium
chloride determination
flex rate for enzymatic assays and smart
wash
reducing that sample to sample carryover
all contribute
to achieving operational excellence and
lastly
the area of focus is that total value of
ownership improvements
so this is abbott's new approach to
clinical chemistry
so sigma strong our commitment to
clinical chemistry
is bringing that assay formulation
improvement
and continuing to leverage our
innovative technologies
so our clinical chemistry offerings
provide customers with that total value
of ownership
here we have listed two studies what
these particular two studies and cases
have realized
is that value of ownership through
reduced quality control
frequency having high performing six
sigma assay
change potential quality control
frequency due to the performance
improved turnaround times and simplified
calibration workflows
all helping to contribute to that total
value of ownership
and also achieving and improving
operational excellence
we will be having a part two of this
session where sten weisgaard
is going to talk a little bit more about
the impact of sigma
quality on lag operations we know that
high performing assays
six sigma quality assays require only
one control rule
with two control levels this can allow
you
to streamline and optimize your qc
strategy and practices
which in turn may help you save time
material and labor
so just to summarize
the importance of sigma quality and the
impact that it has within the laboratory
and
beyond the laboratory six sigma can
benefit the health care system
it can reduce or decrease errors
by nature of six sigma performance and
having
assays that have high six sigma metrics
this in turn can provide consistent
delivery of accurate test results
improve that turnaround time and
ultimately
at the end of all of this is patient is
a patient
helping to improve patient care and also
physician and patient satisfaction
and westgard will now introduce some of
the concepts that he will be presenting
in part two that will go live
session will be on august 11th
ben westgard is the director of client
services and technology
for westgard quality control please join
us on august 11th
thank you for that introduction i'm glad
to be here to
be able to give you a preview
of our talk on august 11th i do want to
acknowledge that
i am being supported by abbott i'm very
thankful for them
to be giving me the opportunity to
connect with you
in the next session one of the goals of
the next session
is to understand why we are using six
sigma
in quality control certainly we know
that change
is constant in the laboratory it happens
with instruments and methods
and automation but even the westgard
rules and how you do qc
has to change now these changes aren't
going to make your life
worse they're going to make your life
better you'll get better results for
patients
easier qc and actually will become less
expensive for you to run those tests
when you have six sigma assays you will
learn that you need
very few westgard rules and you'll see
fewer out of control events
you'll consume fewer supplies run fewer
controls
and your staff will spend less time
chasing
those out of control events
we'll also show you some benefits
in the real world we'll show you a case
study of a laboratory that found
by adopting a six sigma approach to qc
with higher quality assays they had 85
percent fewer
qc failures less time they spent
working that instrument for
troubleshooting and qc events
which resulted over the nine year life
span of that particular instrument
of about a hundred thousand dollars of
soft
labor savings and there are also hard
dollar savings
that we'll discuss in the session
so i hope you'll join us on august 11th
for part two of this series
and understand and learn that six sigma
is not a destination
not a single destination it's a path and
you have to sustain it not just achieve
it once
we'll teach you how to calculate an
analytical sigma metric
identify improvements for qc in your
assay performance
and design better qc with westgard
sigma rules so i look forward to joining
you
um i hope you will be with us on august
11.
thank you dr berman for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
all right let's go ahead and get started
okay your first
question is which
allowable total error pea value
does abbott use to calculate their sigma
values
uh we don't have like a specific value
we look at a particular assay
and see what is recognized as a ta for
that product
oftentimes there's more than one so you
try to
pick the most restrictive but there are
many
sites available such as clia that
offer guidance on the ta to select
thank you okay thank you
now what is the basic um
what is the basic mechanism of flex rate
so uh it's really uh instrument software
that what we do in the instrument is we
set up
two specific read time windows
one is where we expect the majority of
the samples
to give a linear rate uh over time
and usually you know i can't give a
specific percentage but usually it's
like
80 90 80 to 90 of the assays
will give a linear response in that
range but we also have an earlier read
window
such that if the reagent is
the reagent is consumed uh early the
substrate bh is consumed early
we can read at an earlier time point
because we keep all the read profiles of
that sample
so we can just instead of reading later
in time say
10 minutes we can read at five minutes
and
report a result without the user having
to rerun a sample
so it's all controlled by the instrument
software the analysis is exactly the
same
we're looking at a rate of change of the
sample over time
so there's no difference in the response
other than we're
looking at an earlier time point in the
reaction in order
to make sure that we're the rate is
linear over that time
thank you thank you and your next
question
can accuracy studies be done using the
product
calibrators
yes they're they can definitely be done
with a calibrator but if you want to
know
how your system is your system or assays
performing
across other competitor systems or
across other assays
it's better to use a recognized
uh standard but yeah
there's no harm in doing the cabinet
except that since the product is
uh calibrated with that material it
should
it should definitely be accurate against
that calibrating material so you're kind
of
evaluating accuracy against the known
the same material that's used
standardized by using an international
recognized standard
if the calibration is off you'll be able
to detect that with this
international material or reference
material i should say
thank you okay great thank you
all right your next question can you
address the difference between
the limit of detection sensitivity
between
abbott and other manufacturers
uh well abbott has uh is following the
clsi latest guideline
and so we give a value for
limited blank limited detection and
limit of quantitation
so when we say limit of detection you
know
uh how we're how we're doing it some of
the older products
may say limited detection but they may
be actually doing a limited blank
so you really have to look if they're
not following the latest csi
ep17 guidance you need to look at how
which csi guidelines they're using
and how they are defining the limited
detection because often
they're running a blank sample so
their limited detection will seem lower
when actuality you would have to compare
our limited flank
against their limit of detection so you
can't always go
by how they're defining limited
detection you've got to
dig a little deeper to compare the
products
thank you okay great thank you
can we measure quality control using by
this formula
in six sigma metrics can you please
explain it
um
yeah so sigma metrics
are is follows the formula that you
choose a ta you choose
a cd which is derived from some sort of
precision studies such as a 20
20 day precision study that avid uses
and then you're looking at the accuracy
against the target value so you can use
a qc material
but it's not as good as using say a
calibrator which is not as good
as using a reference standard but
certainly people have calculated
sigma values using qc material it just
depends on what you're most comfortable
with
and which material you can get but
you're better off using
a recognized standard than a qc material
because qc material
could have material in the matrix
that affects one particular competitor
system but not another
so qc material is not as consistent as
reference material so that's why uh
you know the lot to lot differences
between qc material can be
very pronounced and so you got to be
careful when you're using those types of
materials
thank you all right
thank you does abbott hil serum indices
provide a quantitative result for
endogenous interference
yes it provides a qualitative as well as
a semi-quantitative value
and you're able to choose whichever one
you want you can get it in default units
or
in international units as well
and abbott has a clinical brochure that
they can that we provide
that with hil expected results
on the avid products thank you
okay great thank you now your next
question
what is the shelf life and stability of
the assays
uh well every assay is uh specific
so if there's a particular asset you're
interested in
we could probably provide that but in
general we tried to get at least 12
months reagent stability
and 12 months calibrated stability but
again it's product specific
thank you
okay great we have a few more questions
here
your next question what information or
direction do you
provide for the assay validation process
we you know if you work with your avid
representative
they'll assess your lab and what you're
doing and give you a recommendation
typically we'll look at precision
linearity
method comparison old versus new method
so again it's kind of essay specific
but i was more than willing to work with
customers to
figure out the best plan for them to use
thank you okay great this next question
i'm not sure if it's a complete question
but it says how many parameter and tests
per
hour
uh the couldn't come as a
it depends on the throughput it's about
1300
tests per hour if you're running the
the potentiometric assays and the
photometric assays
it's going to depend on your mix of
assays
but generally you'll get around 900 to
1300 tests per hour
thank you thank you dr berman we have
one last question here for you
can you explain how the precision value
was obtained
for your next generation abbott clinical
chemistry assays
we did a 20-day precision study with a
minimum of two reagent lots
so by looking over multiple days we can
make sure that we're looking at a good
you know we're getting a good
estimation of the precision values so
that's that's i think doing 20 days
really
gives you a good sense of the precision
and we do it at multiple levels of
controls and panels
that span the dynamic range so
looking at our labeling you can see at a
specific
level especially at medical decision
points what you can
expect in terms of precision for the
asset thank you
thank you dr berman do you have any
final comments for our audience before
we wrap up today
uh i would just like to thank everybody
for listening to today's presentation
and if you have some follow-up questions
later on
we're more than happy to respond to them
either through our avid representative
or sending question comments to the lab
roots
thank you great thank you again dr
berman for your time today and your
important research
we would also like to thank labyrus and
our sponsor abbott for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and further interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labberts
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
please join us on august 11th 10 a.m
pacific 1 pm eastern for part 2
of this series presented by sten
westgard
sten westgard director of client
services and technology for west guard
quality control
we'll discuss how stronger harmonization
builds better
assays simplifies qc and strengthens
results
until next time goodbye